das wäre wirklich eine astronomische
sensation ein forschungsteam aus
südkorea und frankreich werde jetzt den
entscheidenden baustein unseres
universums in frage
die dunkle energie das was fachleute
weltweit seit jahren als gesichert
ansehen soll demnach auf einem
systematischen denkfehler beruhen ist
die dunkle energie tatsächlich nur ein
großer mythos und muss jetzt die gesamte
astrophysik umgekrempelt werden krieg
zum salzen fiktional gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen die dunkle energie ist ein
super mysteriöses thema in der physik
und kosmologie forschungsteams weltweit
verstehen dieses phänomen immer noch
nicht wirklich doch die dunkle energie
agiert wohl wie eine art anti
schwerkraft die das universum
auseinandertreibt zudem wird sie wohl
umso größer je mehr sich der raum
ausdehnt das stockholmer nobelkomitee
zeichnete die drei entdecker der
beschleunigten expansion saul perlmutter
brian schmidt und adam riess im jahr
2011 mit dem nobelpreis aus für die
fachleute weltweit gibt es immer noch
als gesicherte erkenntnis dass die
dunkle energie einen großteil unseres
universums ausmacht 68% des raumes
könnte sie den berechnungen zufolge
ausmache gefolgt von der dunkle materie
mit 27 prozent die sichtbare materie
also sterne planeten und andere objekte
sowie lebewesen würden knapp fünf
prozent ausmachen doch ein
forschungsteam aus südkorea und
frankreich hat jetzt grosse zweifel an
dieser bisherigen annahme demnach gibt
es keine dunkle energie im weltall die
bisherigen berechnungen basieren
möglicherweise alle auf einem
systematischen fehler so die
behauptungen in der aktuellen studie
unsere berechnungen zur dunkle energie
beruhen auf supernovae doch diese
könnten sich möglicherweise ganz anders
verhalten als waren bislang angenommen
hatte konkret geht es um distanzmessung
die auf basis sogenannter 1a supernovae
basieren dabei handelt es sich um sterne
die auf charakteristische art und weise
explodieren wenn ihr nuklearer
brennstoff zur neige geht expertin
experten gegen bis heute davon aus dass
diese explosion überall im weltall auf
dieselbe art und weise ablaufen und
deshalb gelten die 1a supernovae als
sogenannten stand
kerzen sie dienen bei den sehr wichtigen
entfernungsmessung im all zur eichung
vor allem die dehnung der
rotverschiebung verrät astronomie teams
weltweit wie weit objekte entfernt sehen
weil sich weit entfernte objekte
schneller von der erde entfernten
leuchten sie rötlicher als objekt in die
uns näher sind denn die nicht wählen
dieser weit entfernten objekte kommen
bei uns gedehnte an ähnlich war am
dopplereffekt mit schall weil der raum
sich schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit ausdehnt doch die
supernova explosion können keineswegs
als eichen herangezogen werden behauptet
jetzt das internationale forschungsteam
der grund dafür
seit beginn des universums hätten diese
eine evolution durchgemacht und sich
quasi entwickelt supernovae codes sn die
älter sind verhalten sich demnach anders
als die jüngeren und genau diese
erkenntnisse würden alle bisherigen
annahmen zur dunklen energie hinfällig
machen so die behauptung von young
weekly der an der aktuellen studie
beteiligt war
er bezeichnet die bisherigen messungen
zur dunklen energie des weltalls als
zitat artefakt einer brüchigen und
falschen grundannahme das autorenteam
schreibt dazu da sn vorläufer in
würzburgs ihn mit rotverschiebung jünger
werden deutet dieses ergebnis
unweigerlich auf eine ernsthafte
systematischen verzerrung mit
rotverschiebung in der sn kosmologie
gemessen an den normalwerten ist die
leuchtkraft entwicklung von sm damit
signifikant genug um die existenz von
dunkler energie in frage zu stellen wenn
dabei die leuchtkraft entwicklung von
supernovae kurz esm berücksichtigt
würden würden zitat die beweise für das
vorhandensein von dunkler energie
einfach verschwinden
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus südkorea und
frankreich haben das ganze neun jahre
mit einem 2,5 meter teleskop im visier
gehabt und sind sich ihrer sache sicher
anders als die restliche fachwelt die
weitere untersuchungen fordert denn klar
ist falls die aktuelle studie recht
behalten sollte und 1a supernovae vor
milliarden jahren mit anderer
leuchtkraft explodiert sind als heute
würde das nicht nur die bisherigen
berechnungen zur dunklen energie
negieren sondern auch weit
bereiche der astrophysik unserer
aktuellen annahmen über die
zusammensetzung des universums würden
damit auf den kopf gestellt werden es
wäre tatsächlich eine riesige sensation
und so verweist bruno leibundgut von der
europäischen südsternwarte eso nicht nur
weitere analysen sondern auch auf den
beobachtungslisten plank seine messungen
sollen noch im laufe des jahres 2020
ausgewertet werden und neue erkenntnisse
zur dunklen energie ermöglichen eine
mögliche fehlerquelle in der aktuellen
studie sieht der forscher in der
altersangabe einer entscheidenden
lichtquelle 19 milliarden jahre soll sie
demnach als sein
doch das passt laut bruno leibundgut in
keines der bisherigen modelle ist das
universum eine simulation weltraum
wissen anklicken anschauen und astro
comics abonnieren also weltraum wissen
bei us comics bis dann bleibt dran